[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce set lui de sport
à l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire foot us un
début de saison idéal pour les templiers
les élans courtois se sont imposés 14 à
13 face aux pionniers de touraine dans
les toutes dernières minutes
le résumé du match dans ce magazine
rugby versailles a pris une sérieuse
option sur la montée en fin de saison
les versaillais se sont imposés face au
deuxième du classement montesson et
s'envole au classement les détails dans
quelques instants
cyclisme le parcours du paris nice 2019
a été dévoilée cette année le peloton
s'élancera le 10 mars de saint germain
en laye la seconde étape passera quant à
elle par le village des bréviaires dans
le sud des yvelines
reportage à suivre l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football américain les templiers
d'elancourt ont dû s'employer ce samedi
pour remporter leur première victoire de
la saison dans le championnat de 2e
division
ils ont réussi à battre les pionniers de
touraine à domicile dans les toutes
dernières minutes
des images de grégory canal et xavier
jaillard pour le montage le mental le
mental les gars psychologiquement on
doit être au-dessus
on vient de la terreur vous
connaissez les historiques du club feu
tous à la reprise compliquée pour les
templiers dans le championnat de
deuxième division dominés en début de
match sur leur terrain par les pionniers
de touraine
les élans courtois craque une première
fois dans le deuxième quart temps et
sont menés 6 à 0 à la mi temps du match
premier match de saison on connaît pas
l'egypte en face on n'a pas eu le temps
de les voir voir ce qu'ils voient leur
playbook
on n'a rien vu de la saison donc
forcément le temps d'adaptation on a un
jeune cube et donc forcément équitable
et qui peuvent faire l'équipe ne marque
en deuxième période les elins courtois
reviennent à hauteur des pionniers avec
ce tout jeune dans le troisième quart
temps avant que la défense
saint-quentinoise ne cède une nouvelle
fois quelques minutes plus tard
finalement les templiers l'emportent 14
à 13 dans le money time sur l'une des
dernière action du match la victoire est
toujours mérité on s'est battu pour pour
aller la chercher
on était mené tout le match on est parti
le chercher sur dernier drive et au
final on a juste marqué un point de plus
que les autres ce qu'il fallait faire
victoire méritée puisque de 60 du torse
c'est bon à prendre
après la manière n'est pas forcément là
mais avec cette victoire sur le fil les
templiers pointe à la deuxième place du
championnat les footballeurs se
déplaceront sur le terrain des diables
rouges de villepin de ce samedi 19
janvier résultat positif à l'extérieur
pourrait leur permettre de croire en
leur objectif un titre de champion de
deuxième division en fin de saison on ne
jouait pas que sur les terrains de
football américain ce week-end il y
avait également du rugby dans le
championnat honneur versailles a pris
une sérieuse option sur la montée en
s'imposant contre son dauphin à
montesson des images de manon varaldo un
montage de exigea rien n'arrête
versailles les hommes de la cité royale
ont remporté une 10e victoire
consécutive ce dimanche 13 janvier leur
victime du jour monter son deuxième du
classement les versets ils ont emporté
c'est à 5 mais cette fois ci à 100 la
manière directe c'était très haché donc
ya pas eu
c'était dur oui c'était une équipe en
face qui est assez accrocheuse donc
du mal à mettre notre jeu en place
après on n'a pas non plus été trop mis
en difficulté en défense
voilà faut se satisfaire de cette
victoire et de les éloigner du bonus
défensif
avec cette victoire les versailles et
compte douze unités d'avancé sur leur
dauphin monter soit après dix journées
disputées
même si la montée en fédérale 3 semble
s'est dessiné pour versailles le staff
vont continuer à engranger les points
des outils sont claires c'est à dire que
nous on veut rien lâcher
on va essayer de gagner tous nos matches
comme on fait tous les tous les
week-ends le bus devait être aussi
docile intégré pas mal de joueurs comme
on l'a fait avec des rotations pour tout
le monde puisse goûter la belle aventure
est bien évidemment on va essayer
d'aller le plus haut possible après pour
continuer cette série d'invincibilité
versé se rendra sur le terrain de
gif-sur-yvette le huitième du classement
le dimanche 20 janvier toujours en
division honneur mais cette fois ci dans
la poule 2 le sky rugby il continue sa
marche en avant les saint quentinois se
sont imposés 34 à 23 à domicile ce
dimanche face au rugby me l'encontre
sénart
au classement les hommes de thomas payen
sont septièmes avec 20 points engrangés
depuis le début de la saison dans le
championnat de promotion honneur
montigny le bretonneux commence son
année 2010 9 par une victoire lésigny
montain se sont imposés 59 à 0 à
domicile ce dimanche une victoire qui
leur permet d'occuper le haut du
classement avec 35 points
l'objectif montée semble réalisable
cette saison trois divisions plus haut
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir commence également l'année de la
plus belle des manières la plaisir on a
dominé un gennevillois sur le score de
28 à 12
au classement les joueurs de sébastien
rockalies remonte à la huitième place du
championnat avec cette quatrième
victoire engrangée après douze journées
à disputer
on ouvre maintenant une page handball
dans ce magazine montigny le bretonneux
est actuellement à la 7e place de
nationale 2 après neuf journées
disputées pour nous parler du club nous
recevons sur ce plateau le président
christophe reading l'entraîneur denis
cholet ainsi que la nouvelle joueuse de
l'équipe nina algérie cheech jamais
réussi à le dire ni layali tchèque
alors on va tout d'abord revenir sur le
match de ce week-end vous avez gagné 36
à 24 contre lisieux
christophe une réaction alors déjà
content content parce qu'en fait en
termes de championnat
pour nous en fait c'est une bonne chose
les victoires c'est toujours bon c'est
toujours bon pour le public c'est bon
pour nos supporters c'est bon pour nos
partenaires
il est très bon d'encourager une équipe
qui gagne et en fait c'est les voeux du
club donc en tout cas de que ça continue
en ce sens là mais je pense que aussi
bien nina que denys choulet pourront en
fait vous en parler librement de niche
ali oui comment analysez vous ce match
mais voûté une très belle reprise pour
ce que nous avons travaillé durement
avec l'arrivée ni là on a commencé à
retravailler
j'allais dire tout début janvier des
choses
un travail collectif que l'on a vu sur
le terrain dès samedi
donc ça c'est très encourageant parce
que les joueurs se sont appliqués
c'est vrai que lisieux n'était pas bien
classés la dernière qui du championnat
avant dernière oui mais mais c'est
surtout la façon de jouer de montigny
qui m'a vraiment fait plaisir
tout ce que l'on a vu à l'entraînement
été réalisées pendant le match
une application de tout et ça c'est très
important pour la suite du championnat
parce que les jeux eux se sentent
impliqués sur un projet et ça c'est
important
nina il ne faut pas s'enflammer après
une victoire comme celle là moi j'ai
déjà je suis très satisfait avec un
investissement et motivation combat et
je dis aux filles si on va continuer
comme ça on doit pas avoir peur d'aucune
équipe
je crois que on est capable de battre
tout le monde
cette équipe a énormément de potentiel
et le manque peut-être juste culture de
la gagne
il faut qu'elles commencent de croire en
eux et je pense qu'on peut gagner tout
le monde c'était votre premier match
allait continuer vos tenues quand vous
êtes senti sur le terrain je me suis
senti bien
je veux lever le caire déjà ses premiers
matches on montre l'envi
motivation est ce qu'on a fait et je
pense que je me suis bien adapté par
rapport on peut d entraînement que je
fais avec l'équipe il ya encore beaucoup
de choses à corriger mais je pense que
1er mi temps de jeu était vraiment
palois de perfection alors je sais
facilité spectateurs l'ont vu vous avez
un plâtre depuis ce week-end
qu'est ce que vous avez fait enfin déjà
je me suis je fais une fracture de
demandes déjà le premier attaque
et puis par comme c'est dans ma nature
de pas abandonné j'ai continué et c'est
vrai que j'ai eu mal mais comme je
voulais juste gagner le match là donc
j'ai continué je me suis dit ok je suis
pas bon précision donc je vais aider à
mes coéquipières je vais plus distribuer
les jouets match chris smalling et une
réaction par rapport à cette blessure
dissimulé pendant le match
alors on fait on se fait voeu de
malchance sur un premier match car run
in a en fait à porte
m'apporte beaucoup sur sur le groupe
comme l'a pu le dire denis non pas que
en fait ça va vite ça joue bien c'est
plus que ça c'est à dire celle agoussi
la culture du championnat de compétition
de haut niveau est en fait là cette
notion motrices en fait d'apporter à
tous
en fait ces notions là est bien calé
blessé pendant quelques temps en tout
cas elle sera toujours un moteur avec
les autres derrière et au sein du club
de montigny avec le soutien de la ville
de montigny
on a pour vocation en fait de conserver
ce tam envers nous c'est pour ça que
vous l'avez leur côté également pour cet
état d'esprit tout à fait tout à fait en
tout cas si on fait partie clairement
alors vous n'aviez pas joué en
compétition depuis le 24 novembre contre
roy est ce que ça faisait pas trop long
finalement si c'était très long mais
d'un autre côté version ballet j'ose pas
trop non parce que j'avais quand même
des petites blessures à droite à gauche
qui qui commençaient à arriver et je
pense que cette trêve même s'il était un
petit peu longue suite au championnat
d'europe féminin était la bienvenue
donc j'ai mis beaucoup de joueurs au
repos on a continué à travailler un
petit peu plus sur du foncier du cardio
etc
on a laissé un petit peu tombé entre
guillemets le handball que l'on a repris
tout début janvier
mais je pense que c'était nécessaire
parce que les joueuses ont eu un rythme
depuis depuis le mois d'août de travail
important et se sont beaucoup investis
donc c'était déjà dire un petit peu une
trêve de bienvenue pour nous et comment
se sentent les joueuses justement
physiquement à bien écouter physiquement
elles sont en pleine forme
vu le match que l'on a fait on a produit
samedi
et puis surtout très motivés parce que
comme le disait christophe l'arrivée de
nina laura leur a fait pousser un peu
les ailes et puis c'est vrai que c'est
quand même une joueuse professionnelle
même si elle arrêtait sa carrière
internationale il ya quelques temps mais
dans la dans l'état d'esprit dans sa
façon de se préparer dans sa façon
d'être en dehors et sur le terrain c'est
une vraie professionnelle ça fait voies
à nos joueuses formées au club le niveau
qu'elles doivent attendre
et donc c'est très important pour tout
le monde alors il vous reste à peu près
la moitié du championnat
est ce qu'avec nina ça change la donne
et sofremi même si à moi je crois de
rééducation avant de revenir sur les
terrains je vais être avec l'équipe j'ai
envie 80 semble je vois des choses qu on
peut corriger comme je dis on peut faire
mieux et je vais essayer je sais besoin
de rapporter maintenant mes
connaissances et mes expériences sur les
autres choses que sauf en fait oui c'est
totalement ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
faite le
le groupe trouve une motivation
supplémentaire cette envie d'aller au
delà
depuis en fait un mois et demi ou
constater les entraînements communs
depuis avec avec ni dans ces cas-là
cette force en fait de leur apporter
sans plus donc ça se suit bien et on
voit que même si on a vu sur le dernier
match où l'équipe adverse a voulu à un
moment donné elle apprend tout de suite
en prise de street ne prisait une
défense individuelle
ça n'a pas marché parce que les autres
derrière en cette motivation et arrive à
corriger en fait des petites des petites
erreurs techniques qui permettent en
fait d'aller au delà merci à tous les
trois la de passer sur ce plateau on
vous souhaite évidemment de terminer le
plus haut possible dans ce championnat
et avec minable peut-être que ce sera
possible
merci beaucoup du basket à présentera
pas engranger ce week-end sa huitième
victoire de la saison les trappistes se
sont imposés ce samedi soir sur le
terrain de séguinière saint-louis le
score 93 à 81
cette victoire permet aux illinois de se
retrouver à la deuxième place du
championnat après douze journées à
disputer
on continue à part du cyclisme la
présentation officielle du parcours du
paris nice s'est déroulée ce mercredi à
l'hôtel du département à versailles la
course au soleil partira le 10 mars de
saint-jean mansle et le lendemain le
peloton s'élancera des bréviaires dans
le sud des yvelines mélanie poké pour
les images xavier jaillard pour le
montage un mariage qui dure depuis dix
ans le paris-nice partira une nouvelle
fois depuis les yvelines a prêché et où
l'année dernière saint germain en laye a
été retenue comme ville départ de cette
67e édition et coureurs repartiront le
dimanche 10 mars du parc du château pour
une grande boucle de 130 8 5 km à
travers les imminent passant notamment
par touahri montfort l'amaury ou encore
poissy pourquoi saint germain va parce
que saint germain c'est prestigieux
c'est saint germain c'est le château
parce que saint germain il ya des
perspectives formidables aussi pour la
transmission de la télé et parce qu'on
avait été super bien accueilli en 2013
dans un précédent départ de paris nice à
saint germain en laye a pas que le paris
saint-germain il ya énormément de
pratique sportive et donc c'est
important effectivement de montrer que
c'est une étape qui populaire le vélo
c'est très populaire
le lundi 11 mars à 12h35 le peloton
s'élancera des bréviaires pour une étape
de 173,5 kilomètres la petite commune de
1300 habitants située dans le sud des
yvelines deviendra la dix septième ville
du département à accueillir l'épreuve
c'est un événement historique à la fois
pour les bréviaires et pour moi
personnellement on va avoir toutes les
écoles voisines qui va venir participer
avec des départs en vélo donc toutes les
communes voisines
il ya saint germain cité royale célèbre
son château et puis il ya de l'autre
côté les bréviaires la plus petite
commune de paris nice 2010 hop on en est
ravi les compétitions cyclistes c'est ça
sont des grandes villes et des villes
moyennes et des petites communes
les 1300 habitants des bréviaires
pourront notamment voir en action 23
équipes cyclistes et notamment des stars
de la discipline comme le colombien
nairo quintana où les français romain
bardet ou arnaud démare deux étapes de
ce paris-nice 2019 passeront donc par
les yvelines au mois de mars
retour sur le tracé des étapes évinoise
avec l'un des organisateurs françois
lemarchand à mes côtés françois
lemarchand le responsable du tracé de ce
paris-nice 2019
alors qu'est ce qui va être la
spécificité de ce paris-nice 2009 sur
tous dans les yvelines
eh bien ce n'est qu'à chaque fois depuis
deux ans deux dernières années on a eu
une première étape assez discuté dans
l'est dans les yvelines souvenons nous
bois d'arcy
il ya deux ans avec les conditions
atmosphériques étaient qui était en test
mais une course magnifique bien l'an
prochain on espère du soleil bien
évidemment mais
et un parcours dont on va les chevreuse
un peu plus à l'ouest du département sur
des routes qu'on n'a pas encore
emprunter sur sur paris-nice des routes
nouvelles j'espère que cette fois ci
avec une belle arrivée quand même à
saint germain en laye a tenu des loges
avec une longue longue ligne droite pour
finir je pense qu'on se dirige grave
quand même davantage vers une arrivée au
sprint sur cette première étape une
première étape mais pas de prologue
cette année non pas de prologue en a
abandonné l'idée du prologue
c'est vrai que pour paris nice une
habitude c'était de faire un prologue à
prologue c'est quelque part une
présentation des coureurs mais
on préfère d'entrée de jeu matt les
coureurs sur la même ligne de départ et
le premier qui reprend sa cause portent
le maillot donc c'est quelque chose qui
est bien aussi
contrairement au prologue ou là le
prologue et des écarts peuvent être
établies et le porteur du maillot risque
de ramener le maillot deux trois voire
quatre jours plus loin tandis que là le
ça peut changer dès le lendemain donc
pour nous c'est plus intéressant
ces premières étaient impatients les ça
sera pour quels types de coureurs
quelques noix ce soit pour les
sprinteurs donc pour les sprinteurs
parce que comme je disais tout à l'heure
et les deux dernières années ça il ya eu
un lot de surprises sur les premières
étapes
je pense que l'an prochain les équipes
de sprinteurs ne vont pas se faire
piéger même s'il ya du vent même si à
tout ça du mauvais temps je pense que
tout le monde va faire en sorte que ça
arrive au sprint faut pas oublier qu'on
a un très beau plateau de sprinteurs
donc les sprinteurs quand ils se
déplacent c'est pour gagner c'est pas
pour laisser partir des échappés
donc une belle arrivée au sprint et ce
serait reliable déjà ça passe largement
les le lendemain ça sera des bréviaires
que le peloton s'élancera encore une
petite commune dans les yvelines qui
sera mise à l'honneur
toujours les petites communes ces
salades vertes âge du cyclisme c'est
qu'on amène les champions vers les
petites communes 1300 habitants jeu leur
a permis tant on n'est pas dans un stade
les champions sont aux mains des stars
dans les grandes villes mellal avantages
du vélo c'est qu'on peut se déplacer
donc les gens peuvent voir les champions
donc les bréviaires oui je connais pas
ce que je je me suis souvent entraîné
par la balle et ses déroutes très
sympathique pour aller pour les faire du
vélo et là il y aura donc un départ de
paris-nice tout partira par les vaux de
cernay ensuite pour la côte de senlis et
on quittera le département à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines la nation
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter au
paris-nice 2019 du soleil du soleil mais
il y aura du soleil sera le di bacco
coup dans les yvelines
si on a eu quand même non non non il y
en a eu il y en a eu mais savez quand il
pleut quand il ya du mauvais temps c'est
la quête des plus belles courses dans
quelque part nous chipent le c'est comme
ça et on aura une belle course quand
même merci beaucoup
le paris nice ce sera dans les yvelines
ce sera le dimanche 10 mars et le lundi
11 mars
on continue à parler de cyclisme mais
cette fois ci sur piste la fédération
française a dévoilé sa sélection sprint
pour la cinquième manche de la coupe du
monde en nouvelle-zélande
une liste où figurent notamment le
plaisir ou à michael d'almeida ainsi que
quentin lafargue le pistard du vélo-club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines et
de sportifs qui s'entraînent au
vélodrome nationale participeront à des
épreuves de vitesse à cambridge du 18 au
20 octobre est entre ont évidemment de
décrocher des médailles sont
actuellement en stage à nouméa en
nouvelle calédonie un mot de golf un peu
plus de 100 jours après la ryder cup
2018 le golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines a repris un rythme de
croisière plus traditionnelle
cette année la structure doit tout de
même faire face à une augmentation du
nombre de pratiquants sur ces green le
golf organisera également en octobre
2019 la 103e édition de l'open de france
nous avons pu rencontrer son directeur
paul hermitage entretien après une année
2008 exceptionnelle quel sera l'avenir
du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2019 pour
répondre à cette question j'ai à côté de
moi le directeur du golf national de
saint-quentin dans l'aisne hermitage
mais on veut bonne année meilleurs voeux
alors quel sera l'avenir du coup de de
ce golf pour 2019
alors est ce qu'on sera dans le blues ou
est ce que justement il rappelle des
baisses d'activité s'est déjà passé
c'était difficile octobre novembre
c'était un peu un peu tristounet les
derniers camions sont partis vers le 20
novembre mais depuis non non on a bien
fait notre deuil et tout va bien je vous
rassure non 2019 2019 a été une année un
peu plus calme c'est vrai mais on en a
besoin on en a grandement besoin on sent
une une demande
accrue pour venir fouler les faits et
des légendes on va dire comme ça donc en
à une demande forte des joueurs on a un
programme un calendrier d'animations
assez assez fourni déjà et puis des
commandes des tours opérateurs et puis
et puis des gens qui a envie qui en vue
qui ont adoré
à la télévision qui vont venir visiter
donc on va s'occuper plutôt de nos
clients de nos amis de nos de nos
abonnés en 2019 avant d'attaquer à de
nouveaux projets vous avez des
réservations france ou à l'étranger
les deux les deux la france sur tous les
événements
je dirais organisés par des agences le
programme de paris va revenir ici ça
c'est une annonce après
beaucoup d'années d'absence d'ailleurs
donc on est très contents très fiers
et puis à l'international nos carnets de
commandes sont déjà bien remplis et du
coup il ya également l'open de france
qui se déroule ici chaque année
est ce que cette année le déplacement de
la date de fin juin à octobre va avoir
des conséquences ici sur le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors il ya eu beaucoup de discussions
et de débats autour de cette nouvelle
date
moi je peux je peux vous garantir d'un
point de vue du golf national qu'on
l'accueille avec beaucoup d'optimisme
parce que octobre c'est pas une si
mauvaise date pour ça déjà d'être
problème était oh non non non on peut
avoir une très très belle arrière saison
regarder la ryder cup cette année le
temps magnifique c'était début fin
septembre début octobre donc on n'est
que 15 jours après ça mais surtout pour
le golf national ce qui est positif
c'est qu'on retrouve un mois de juin un
plein et on retrouve un mois de
septembre plein sur notre calendrier ce
qui nous permet de travailler encore
plus sereinement donc ça pour les
golfeurs déjà c'est c'est hyper positif
pour l'activité économique du golf
national c'est très important également
de d'avoir cette bouffée d'oxygène et
maintenant pour l'open
non je pense que la date peut être très
bien parce que c'est juste avant la fin
de la saison donc il va avoir quelques
enjeux quand même il y aura des bons
joueurs oui bah oui je pense qu'on va
vers quelque chose
un compromis
actuel
dans où et on va essayer de d'embellir
le plateau de joueurs on va le dire
comme ça on va essayer d'emblée embellir
le pas toujours pour compenser ce
changement de date et ou penser que les
joueurs vont suivre également après
cette ryder cup qui s'est déroulé d'une
façon merveilleuse ici au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
oui je pense qu'il y aura déjà parcours
c'est avant tout faire absolument je
pense qu'on aura déjà un côté souvenirs
souvenirs pèlerinage même vielles on
peut presque dire
donc ouais non mais tout à fait
optimiste qu'on retrouve trois ou quatre
joueurs de l'équipe européenne
cette nouvelle date est ce que ça va
influencer peut-être sur les le nombre
de pratiquants peut-être ici au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines y
aura peut-être un peu plus de
pratiquants alors sur les périodes
rejoint notamment et juillet qui sont
les paroles on espère nous laiteuse les
deux si vous demandez à nos collègues
dans les différents golf autour dans les
yvelines si vous demandez les mois les
plus forts si je vois un récepteur en
moi donc pour nous c'est franchement une
bonne nouvelle septembre on l'avait pas
cette année mais on avait la rider et on
le regrette pas aux cons bien au
contraire
et puis l'open de france a toujours été
dernier week-end de juin
et comme on ferme 10 à 15 jours avant on
a toujours perdu la moitié du mois de
juin est justement la moitié ou c'est la
fin de la période scolaire où les gens
ils ont un peu plus de temps les
vacances approchent ça sent bon
donc on a toujours manqué un petit peu
nous d'activité notre personne qui a
vécu une année 2008 exceptionnelle c'est
alejandro reyes le super intendant du
parcours qui est également sur la ryder
cup 2018 qu'en est il de l'avenir de
alejandro reyes oui c'est une bonne
question à l'herbe rouge jeunes
il est doué chemin voyage avec le
fantastique depuis quatre cinq ans alors
j'ai une bonne nouvelle c'est que on est
garanti de l'avoir à nos côtés pendant
encore trois ans puisqu'on a signé un
contrat avec alejandro et s pour qu'ils
gardent un oeil et tout son talent sur
l'albatros l'aigle et loiselet donc il
est consultant pour les trois parcours
tout le site
mais sur un contre ajustement de
consulting donc on va avoir à peu près
un tiers de son temps et il va voguer à
d'autres vocations avec d'autres golfs
et on lui souhaite beaucoup de succès
autant de succès qui nous a apporté ici
au golf national en tout cas une bonne
nouvelle peut en cacher une autre c'est
que ça nous a permis de promouvoir son
assistant donc son numéro 2 qui a
travaillé j'ai séparé le cas l'udc
appiah et qui a travaillé dans l'ombre
je dirais dans les reins drôme et qui
est jeune qui a moins de 30 ans qui on
va dire de faire aussi bien que
qu'alejandro avec le soutien d'
alejandro donc moi je dirais que c'est
une très très bonne nouvelle pour nous
tous ici garder
cette proximité avec alejandro est aussi
avoir un nouveau talent à découvrir dans
la question est-ce que 2019 prépare déjà
2024 les jeux olympiques qui se
dérouleront ici
bref national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines clairement on
y pense on y pense beaucoup
quel format de jeu comment ça va
s'organiser mais je pense qu'on a une
petite échéance avant ou deux c'est
premièrement je pense qu'on verra plus
clair après japon après les jeux
olympiques du japon et comment se
déroule le golfe là bas avant de
projeter comment ça peut vraiment être
ici la direction du cojo était ici pour
la ryder cup ça leur a vachement plus
qu'ils en vue donc parce que ça alors à
amener de nouvelles idées d'autres idées
donc la donne peut changer encore mais
c'est sûr que les jo
le golf sera ici entre temps on a
échangé un du monde championnats du
monde amateurs 2022 1994
vous n'étiez pas encore nés mais tiger
woods a gagné ici donc on va découvrir
d'autres champions on va être sur un
plan planétaire bien avant les jo
merci beaucoup pour les amis tête j'ai
encore une bonne année 2009 on vous le
souhaite en tout cas intérêt fils aussi
merci beaucoup merci
le directeur du golf national paul
ermite lgt mardi dernier au voeu de
guyancourt il a reçu à cette occasion la
médaille de la ville des mains du maire
de la commune marie christine le tarnec
distinction pour le remercier du travail
accompli pendant l'organisation de la
ryder cup 2018 on écoute sa réaction et
et au micro d'aurélie ablement surpris
très honoré c'est vrai que moi je je je
faisais mon job entre guillemets donc ce
n'est pas comme on dit lors du bénévolat
et et
au coeur d'une action de charité ou
d'associatifs tant que
plutôt sympa de savoir que ce qu'on a
fait à une impact positif pour la vie
c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]